danke tina das sah ja es ist der
zweitgrößte haushalt in der geschichte
der bundesrepublik ist auch die
zweithöchste neuverschuldung in der
geschichte der bundesrepublik mit fast
140 milliarden euro und wer weiß was
noch kommt in diesen zeiten von corona
von ukraine krieg von klimawandel und
inflation also alles noch nicht
abzusehen so richtig und außerdem gibt
es da noch den sonderposten bundeswehr
mit 100 milliarden möglichen neuen
schulden das ist ja noch nicht
ausgemacht sondern es geht hier in
erster linie mal um kreditermächtigung
also ein bundeshaushalt der
vergleichsweise spät verabschiedet wird
das hat mit dem regierungswechsel zu tun
bislang haben die ministerium mit einer
vorläufigen haushaltsplanung gearbeitet
demnächst können sie dann auch richtig
das geld ausgeben was ihnen zugestanden
wird durch den deutschen bundestag und
gleichwohl ist es ein haushalt mit
unglaublich vielen unbekannten ich habe
die stichworte am anfang schon gesagt
also durchaus wert auch im vorfeld schon
mal über das zu sprechen was uns hier
die nächsten vier tage erwartet ich
freue mich dass bei uns sind gesine
lötzsch die stellvertretende vorsitzende
der linksfraktion und
haushaltspolitische sprecherin und
vorsitzende im haushaltsausschuss ist ja
auch schon mal gewesen und ich freue
mich dass christian dürr bei uns ist der
vorsitzende der fdp-fraktion auto gegen
einen schönen guten morgen von bei
direkt mal bei ihnen an ausgerechnet die
fdp und ihr bundesfinanzminister haben
die zweitgrößte neuverschuldung in der
geschichte der bundesrepublik
mitzuverantworten früher wurden
finanzminister einmal sparkommissare
genannt
huldigten der schwarzen null das tun sie
im prinzip auch aber jetzt wird ihr
finanzminister schon schulden lindner
genannt geht es in diesen zeiten nicht
anders mit so vielen schulden ja man
muss das ins rechte licht rücken glaube
ich dieser haushalt ist ein auftakt für
den haushalt 2023 den wir schon in
wenigen wochen nach der
parlamentarischen sommerpause beraten
werden und das ist ein haushalt wo die
schuldenbremse wieder einhalten werden
was diesen haushalt betrifft herr
schärfer machen war 100 milliarden euro
weniger schulden als die große koalition
und reduzieren die ausgaben um 7 70
milliarden euro daran sehen sie schon
die richtung aber auf den haushalt auf
den ich mich persönlich richtig voll ist
der kommende da wird die schuldenbremse
wieder eingehalten es kommt halt
bekanntermaßen immer auf die perspektive
an ändert aber nichts daran dass es der
zweithöchste der zweitgrößte haushalt
ist und die zwei größten neuverschuldung
auch es gibt frauen in diesem haushalt
viele punkte wo sie sagen müssten
eigentlich ja beispielsweise
entlastungspaket zuschüsse für familien
mit kindern es gibt mehr zuschüsse für
die rentenversicherung trotzdem sind sie
nicht zufrieden warum ich kann auch gar
nicht zufrieden sein weil ich sehe dass
es natürlich zuschüsse gibt die reichen
aber bei weitem nicht aus wir haben
jetzt eine inflation von 7,9 prozent und
alles was an zuschüssen gewährt wird
wird damit schon völlig aufgefressen
also brauchen wir andere maßnahmen
ersten wir sind gegen eine hohe
neuverschuldung und dafür brauchen wir
an einnahmen also es gibt ja zum
beispiel italien jetzt diese über
gewinnen steuer da sagen wir das
brauchen wir auch bei uns hier in der
bundesrepublik denn wir haben ja die
paradoxe situation dass zum beispiel die
anzahl der einkommensmillionäre
gestiegen ist und dass viele doch große
gewinne machen in der krise und auf der
anderen seite viele menschen verarmen
und viele große projekte der ampel
koalition sind überhaupt noch nicht
angegangen worden zum beispiel die
kindergrundsicherung zum beispiel das
bürgergeld und wenn ich jetzt höre im
kommenden jahr soll die schuldenbremse
wieder ziehen dann sind diese projekte
alle nur finanzierbar wenn man wirklich
die reichen zur kasse bittet ganz kurz
mal zwischendurch weil sie am anfang
ihrer antwort gesagt haben wir sind
gegen eine so hohe verschuldung aber
generell gegen schulden sind hier
eigentlich nicht oder haben sie da ihre
position als linke denn die
schuldenbremse ist ein ökonomischer
irrweg da sehen ja inzwischen alles
missverstanden das kommt natürlich alle
bewusst sich natürlich fragen ist es
nötig so viele schulden zu machen oder
das ist nicht viel wichtiger die
einnahmen zu stärken und wir sagen wir
brauchen vermögensabgaben wir brauchen
ein gerechtes steuersystem und keine
steuererleichterungen für reiche da sind
wir natürlich auf der ganz anderen seite
die fdp hat ja völlig andere vorstellung
als wir deswegen haben sie beide ja auch
eingeladen weil wir unterschiedliche
positionen hören wollen und auch gucken
wie unterschiedlich man eine bestimmte
position probleme auch rangehen kann mit
welchen lösungen wollen sie direkt dazu
ja sehr gerne zur schuldenbremse habe
ich vorhin was gesagt die werden wir
bekommen ja wieder einhalten
die fragt er an der stelle auch noch mal
direkt nach irgendwie was macht sie da
so sicher sie können doch überhaupt
nicht absehen wie die wie die
einnahmeentwicklung wird sie können
überhaupt nicht absehen wie die ausgaben
werden sie dass es ja ich will ihnen ein
beispiel sagen weil wir das gegenteil
tun dessen was frau lötzsch gerade
vorgeschlagen hat die werde nämlich
nicht die steuern ein bundeshaushalt ist
dann solide wenn die wirtschaft wieder
brummt und da müssen wir hinkommen dass
arbeitsplätze wieder geschaffen werden
in deutschland nur wenn die wirtschaft
insgesamt funktioniert funktioniert auch
die einnahmen das macht man nicht indem
man die steuerlast erhöht sondern dem
man beispielsweise entlastet das tun wir
gerade wir entlasten die menschen in
deutschland übrigens gerade kleine und
mittlere einkommen in höhe von 37
milliarden euro bei der einkommenssteuer
sogar dauerhaft nicht nur für dieses
jahr über tank rabatt haben wir schon
gesprochen in den letzten wochen also
all die dinge tun wir für kleine und
mittlere einkommen dass es sich lohnt zu
arbeiten und nur dann ist ein haushalt
solide also ich bin sehr zuversichtlich
was die schuldenbremse betrifft und
würde ausdrücklich zum gegenteil dessen
raten was frau lötzsch gerade gesagt hat
nicht steuererhöhungen sind das gebot
der zeit sondern steuerentlastung sind
das gebot der zeit die frage ist immer
steuererhöhungen für wen und ich habe ja
schon das beispiel italien genannte
haben wir also diese über gewinn steuer
warum sollten wir uns nicht an diesem
beispiel orientieren und wir haben ganz
eindeutig krisen gewinnerinnen und
krisengewinner wir haben diesen fehler
des tankverbots was ja eine
steuerermäßigung ist dann müsste man
ganz anders ran geben die große
energiekonzerne profitieren im
augenblick ungeheuer von der situation
und es gibt in zum beispiel in portugal
gibt es eine preisregulierung nf preises
grenze eine höchstgrenze die
festgesetzten oder das wäre der richtige
weg alles länder die weniger
wirtschaftlich erfolgreich sind als
deutschland das müsste frau laut stadt
noch hinzufügen das bedeutet auch
geringere einkommen im durchschnitt und
so weiter und so fort das kauft man sich
alles mit ein wenn man die steuerpolitik
machen würde die die linken dort
vorschlagen deswegen rate ich
ausdrücklich zu wachstum und zu
wirtschaftlichem erfolg dann geht es
auch den kleinen und mittleren einkommen
besser und einsatz der schärfer wenn ich
das sagen darf zu über gewinn steuer
über gewinne aus sicht der linken haben
dann zur zeit in den letzten monaten
auch die betreiber von erneuerbaren
energien anlagen gemacht wenn wir die
jetzt zusätzlich belasten obwohl wir
brauchen für die co2 neutralität wäre es
genau der falsche anreize über gewinn
steuer ist ein passwort wenn ich das mal
so neudeutsch sagen darf was mein sind
also ein alters das wird immer in den
raum geworfen nach dem motto hilf total
super ist aber nicht der fall ist extrem
kompliziert denn diese über gewinne die
müssten ja definiert werden also war
dann ist ein gewinn ein
ungerechtfertigter über gewinnen macht
das steuersystem extrem kompliziert ich
rechne dort nicht mit einnahmen und
nochmal im gegenteil wir brauchen eine
wirtschaft die wächst und die
investieren kann das macht man nicht
durch steuerung ich hab da mal ne frage
so einem sogenannten passwort mich kennt
hätte um 10 grad irgendwie wo er morgen
die stunde der wahrheit dann beginnt
oder sagen wir die tage der wahrheit
weil man kann ja morgen noch nicht
wirklich sagen ob es so funktioniert
aber alles sieht danach aus dass die
einzigen die tatsächlich davon
profitieren die mineralölkonzerne zu
sein scheint und nicht die idee
autofahrerinnen und autofahrer denn der
preis scheint sich ja nicht tatsächlich
irgendwie zu reduzieren also ich bin
dankbar dass helm und das ist in
deutschland der chef des
bundeskartellamtes sich gestern geäußert
hat und gesagt hat er wird genau
hingucken erwartet übrigens gleiches von
robert habeck als zuständigen
bundeswirtschaftsminister für diesen
bereich um deinen tank rabatt muss man
eines sagen 60 prozent der menschen in
deutschland wohnen im ländlichen raum so
wie ich kommen beispielsweise aus
niedersachsen ich habe manchmal das
gefühl dass diese debatte um den tank
rabatt die ja gerade die pendlerinnen
und pendler über drei monate entlasten
soll das ist so ein bisschen aus sicht
der jenige führt wird die in berlin mit
der u bahn zur verfügung
aber nicht alle die frage ist eine
andere die frage ist ja ob tatsächlich
die 60 prozent die sie angesprochen
haben davon profitieren oder ob es
andere sind genau das kartellamt wird
genau darauf achten deswegen bin ich
herrn und den präsidenten des
kartellamtes sehr sehr dankbar erwartet
gleich ist von robert habeck dass dieses
geld also diese entlastung bei der
benzinsteuer bei der dieselsteuer das
ist tatsächlich bei den pendlerinnen und
pendlern ankommen ja es bei aller
achtung vor dem bundeskartellamt das ist
natürlich in dieser frage absolut ein
zahnloser tiger denn das
bundeskartellamt wollte erst im nachgang
tätig und bewertet dinge die abgelaufen
sind und was wir brauchen ist wirklich
eine festsetzung der preise und wir
hatten ja auch preis genehmigungen in
deutschland für energiepreise bis zum
jahr 2005 ist das abgeschafft wurde also
das ist ja nicht alles irgendwie vor 100
jahren gewesen oder so sondern in einer
sehr sehr kurzen vergangenheit und wir
müssen zu bestimmten regularien zu
gehören und die ideologie der fdp der
markt regelt alles und reguliert alles
hat sich ja nicht als erfolgreich
erwiesen das sehen wir jetzt in den
krisen besonders ich darf das ganz klar
sagen erschüttern ich kenne kein
einziges land der welt in dem
planwirtschaftliche ideen von
preisfestsetzung dazu geführt haben dass
gerade kleine und mittlere einkommen
profitieren im gegenteil die sind immer
ärmer geworden also die idee
planwirtschaftlich unterwegs zu sein hat
in der geschichte der menschheit nicht
funktioniert und aktuell funktioniert es
in keinem land der welt deswegen bitte
weg von diesen ideen des letzten
jahrhunderts lasst uns über innovationen
nachdenken ich dafür steht ja auch die
ampel wurde ich damals ich schlage vor
wir waren mal zwei drei tage ab und
gucken wie sich das entwickelt es bleibt
trotzdem ein eingriff in der markt auch
wenn sie finde ich jedenfalls auch wenn
sie da anderer meinung die
steuerentlastung die vitrinen aus maine
griffin einmal übrigens eingriff in der
man durch die fdp entlastung bei steuern
er nennt es anders frau lötzsch ich habe
eine andere frage noch es gibt ein
strategiepapier aus dem
finanzministerium unter anderem sind
geplant hilfen für bürgerinnen und
bürger sowie für firmen sie fordern
schnelle hilfe für die bevölkerung
insbesondere für die die in diesen
zeiten dringende unterstützung nötig
haben was ist also falsch an den
überlegungen aus dem finanzministerium
gestern haben wir von finanzminister
lindner gehört er weg ja sogar eine
steuerreform ja aber seine steuerreform
wird natürlich nicht die entlasten denen
es am schlechtesten geht und darum haben
wir viel mehr sympathie für den
vorschlag von hubertus heil den er
allerdings wahrscheinlich nicht
durchsetzen kann innerhalb der koalition
sondern wir müssen den leuten direkt das
geld geben leute die ein geringes
einkommen haben uns eine dadurch relativ
geringe einkommenssteuer oder lohnsteuer
bezahlen profitieren natürlich von
solchen steuer veränderung viel viel
weniger als menschen mit einem hohen
einkommen und darum sagen wie direkte
entlastung die idee des klima geldes von
bertus heil war eine gute idee die
gingen in die richtige richtung aber die
ist ja gestern schon wieder von
finanzminister lindner plattgemacht
worden und da sieht man natürlich auch
dass diese parteien eigentlich gar nicht
so richtig zusammenpassen klima geld
habe ich auch hier stehen warum kein
sondervermögen armutsbekämpfung
beispielsweise armutsbekämpfung ist das
der beste motor um das zu beseitigen die
armut in deutschland sind neue jobs und
deswegen rate ich auch dringend davon ab
sozusagen jetzt eher arbeitslosigkeit zu
subventionieren an stattdessen sollte
man kleine und mittlere einkommen
entlasten haben im ersten schritt getan
arbeitnehmerpauschbetrag den
grundfreibetrag über die
pendlerpauschale sprach ich vorhin schon
die haben wir im fokus auch im herbst da
kommt der sogenannte progression bericht
darum geht ja diese debatte also da
sehen wir dass die inflation sich auf
steuersystem auswirkt in dem die leute
ungerecht sich teilweise höhere steuern
zahlen obwohl sie real gar nicht höhere
einkommen haben und da müssen wir die
leute entlassen und deswegen werden wir
in der ampel darüber reden ich bin
hubertus heil für den impuls dankbar die
instrumente halte ich an der stelle
finde ich zielführende habe andere
instrumente nämlich im steuerrecht und
das betrifft diejenigen die jeden morgen
aufstehen sehr hart arbeiten die müssen
wir entlasten ist doch verrückt dass wir
in deutschland dann 1,4 fachen
durchschnittseinkommen dem 14 fachen des
durchschnittseinkommens schon den
spitzensteuersatz zahlen das sind dinge
an die wir angehen sollten also ich muss
da gleich mal einen haken von wegen
arbeitslosigkeit subventionieren das ist
natürlich ich musste so ein bisschen
zuspitzen kollege gerne zynische
bemerkung uns geht es ja auch darum das
ist unheimlich viele menschen gibt die
wie es immer so formulieren morgens
aufstehen es gibt übrigens auch leute
die nachtschicht arbeiten die wir
vergessen die wir haben dann auch ein
recht darauf tagsüber zu schlafen aber
das nur nebenbei deren einkommen reicht
nicht zum leben und alles was jetzt
zusätzlich kommt durch die inflation
durch die steigenden preise wird
aufgefressen und darum geht es und darum
war dieser vorschlag der direkten
entlastung der leute nicht über umwege
und euer unser steuersystem ist schon
sehr kompliziert nicht über umwege
sondern einer direkten entlastung sehr
richtig und das werden wir auch weiter
fördern und unterstützen durch die
direkte entlassung ist es ja wenn man
weniger steuern zahlt dann geht das
direkte netto in die tasche der menschen
und so sollten was machen das betrifft
mich wiederhole das kleine und mittlere
einkommen frau lötzsch und insofern
diese debatten um spitzenverdiener und
sonst was ist aus meiner sicht fehl am
platz wir haben zum ersten und zweiten
ins leistungspaket gemacht die kleinen
und mittleren einkommen entlastet und
wir werden im herbst darüber diskutieren
ob wir in der breite entlasten und das
steuersystem an darstellen also sie
wollen die spitzenverdiener wieder und
leisten damit jetzt noch mal deutlich
gesagt
der große unterschied zwischen uns das
ist ja auch gut dass es die unterschiede
erkennbar sind in der politik und jede
menge live als würden wir ja wie
definieren sie leistungsträger zum
beispiel eine pflegekraft die aufstocken
muss ist die kleine leistungsträgerinnen
also natürlich hätte sie das ich bin
gelassen wir durch den erhöhten
grundfreibetrag ich verstehe gar nicht
warum sie im bundestag dagegen gestimmt
haben also genau die entlasten wir durch
den erhöhten nein wir sind wir natürlich
für die antwort sind für die erhöhung
der grundfreibeträge das ja klar aber
menschen die so ein geringes einkommen
haben dass sie quasi nicht mal in diese
steuer kategorie fallen den nutzt das
was kollege doha propagiert überhaupt
nicht die brauchen eine direkte
unterstützung team besser wäre endlich
dass sie ordentlich bezahlt werden und
sogar müsste der bundestag natürlich
auch mutige schritte ergreifen um die
mindestlöhne zu erhöhen da ist die rtt
am freitag da ist die fdp
das ist ein kleiner schritt in die
richtige richtung aber nicht ausreichend
wird auch alles sofort wieder
aufgefressen und da brauchen wir größere
schritte denn es werden ja überall
menschen gesucht die arbeitgeber suchen
fachkräfte und sie müssen sie bezahlen
das ist die entscheidende frage und so
könnten wir noch mindestens eine
viertelstunde weitermachen nicht stolz
sind hochinteressant hoch interessanter
austausch des wie ich finde und auch
sehr klar und auf den punkt ich habe
auch noch jede menge andere stichworte
hätte ich gehabt haben wir aber nicht ja
die zeit unsere zeit ist um um 10 uhr
beginnt die sitzung drin follett vielen
dank dass ihr heute morgen bei uns
gewesen hätte vielen herzlichen dank